- Müssen wir jetzt gleich
noch mal gucken ...
Heute ist es recht heiß draußen.
Das sind alles Obstsorten, die
sind sehr anfällig auf Wärme.
Wenn wir hier nicht immer laufend
kontrollieren, kann es gut sein,
dass wir in einer Stunde ganz
viele Obstfliegen hier haben, ne?
Wäre ganz schön, wenn du da gleich mal
drüberguckst. Wirklich hundert Prozent.
Wir müssen immer drauf achten, dass hier
immer alles hundertprozentig frisch ist. Ja?
Alles klar!
- Dann schau ich mal drüber.
- Ja, alles klar. Gut.
- Hör mal, pass mal auf.
Mir fällt gerade auf,
du räumst die jetzt einfach nur davor.
- Ja.
- Du musst schon ein bisschen
so aufs Datum achten.
- Ach so.
- Hier: 9.8., 12.8.
und da hinten sind dann wieder andere
Daten. Da musst du ein bisschen aufpassen,
dass du hier den 12.8. nicht davorräumst.
- Ach so, okay.
- Erst die alte Ware nach vorne
und die neue dann dahinter.
- So. Jetzt machen wir
hier gleich eine Bestellung.
- Ja.
- Das Gerät ist auch schon
so weit eingestellt.
Wo wir drauf achten müssen,
dass wir hiermit einlesen mit
dem gelben Knopf. Du siehst?
- Aha. Okay.
- So. Am besten nimmst du das
MDE-Gerät mal selber in die Hand, ja?
Einfach mal … mit dem gelben
Knopf machst du die Bestellung.
Mit dem Scanner dann an das Etikett.
Du brauchst auch nichts entern.
Da vorne … genau. Eins! Du
brauchst nichts machen.
Du brauchst kein Enter drücken.
Du brauchst jetzt nicht mehr bestätigen.
Du kannst immer wieder weiter
an den EAN-Code rangehen
und dann einfach bestellen.
So, jetzt prüfen wir mal eben
vorne den Lieferanten,
einfach mal, ob nicht
irgendwas beschädigt ist.
So, jetzt zeige ich dir gerade mal,
wie hier der Kontrollvorgang ist.
Du kontrollierst direkt beim Auspacken.
Du kannst dann, falls was
fehlen sollte, direkt anrufen:
„Hey, mir fehlt Ware.“
Das funktioniert auch so.
- Okay.
- So, ich bräuchte dann bitte
einmal noch eine Unterschrift.
- Alles klar.
- Schönen Tag noch.
- Ich wünsch dir auch einen
schönen Tag, ne! Tschau.